declared the country is now in a state
of emergency as demonstrators in Cusco
looted stores burned a television
station and tried to strum the airport
in another city in puno protesters also
tried to force entry to the runway
the Army has been deployed to assist the
police in protecting key infrastructure
with blockades on main highways and
expanding protests boluarte brought
forward the plan for general elections
again to be held she says a year from
now
legally the timetables will be okay for
2024 however making readjustments this
can be brought forward to December 2023
because before that date legally it
would not be possible
protesters are demanding general
elections now Ronald is kovilka came all
the way from Peru's Amazon region he
says he wants his voice heard
we want Congress to close a change of
the Constitution and the new elections
[Music]
these demonstrators are hoping former
president Pedro Castillo will be freed
one week after he tried to dissolve
Congress suspended legal protections and
ordered the Army to patrol the streets
the former president is detained on
Rebellion charges it is likely the judge
will order that Castile remain under
arrest Castillo says his freedom is
being restricted and asked the
inter-american commission for human
rights to intercede
in a handwritten letter Castillo's
social unrest
I hold you in all your circle
responsible for the Ferocious attack on
my competitors I call on the organized
people to remain alert and optimistic
is
the legitimate leader
[Music]
my president has been elected by the
people he is the president of the people
he has come from the highlands the white
people do not want us
Castillo supporters say they will remain
outside the prison for the long run
they've set up a communal kitchen to
sustain themselves and their costs while
the Judiciary decides Castillo's fate
Mariana Sanchez Lima Peru